hey everyone this is kevin from the
chess website comm and today we're gonna
be looking at day number four from the
2017 champions showdown if you're not
familiar with this tournament there's
eight individuals and they're matched up
against one person they're gonna be
playing that person for 30 games over a
four-day stretch those range from rapid
to blitz games blitz being the faster of
the two and on day four which we are at
they play twelve games and they only
have five minutes on at their clock so
they end up playing one individual a lot
of chess games the winner of the
heads-up battle will get $60,000 the
loser in each of the heads that battle
will get $40,000 now for most of the
competitors six of them this is it this
is the final day for Magnus Carlsen and
Dingley and they just started yesterday
so they were on day two today so we will
have coverage of the next two days as
they play day three and four but wanted
to go over one of the matches from one
of the closest heads-up battles and
that's between Wesley soand Linda
Dominguez over the first three days Luna
Dominguez has a small advantage one game
in hand against Wesley so but day number
four there's 12 blitz games they will be
playing so anything can happen
game number one went to Wesley so he had
the white pieces got a victory which
brings us to game number two Dominguez
trying now with the white pieces come
back get that victory and then continue
that momentum going on so we will start
with Dominguez with the white pieces
pawn to d4 I'm Knight f6 Knight f3 pawn
d5 pawn e3 Pawnee six not a system that
we see that often knight here to d2 pawn
b6 Bishop here d3 Bishop b7 castle on
the King side if you're not too familiar
with this system this is the Colley
system and it's something you usually
don't see at the highest level play it
is very sound and many times you don't
even have to worry what your opponent's
gonna do is black because you're not
really putting too much material in the
center of the board so you can usually
do
and they really can't stop you you're
not trying to force anything and so this
is a way many times in a blitz game
someone will play this to stop their
opponent from being super aggressive or
if there's a prepared line that they've
been you know shoving down your throat
for a few games here this just says okay
let's come back to just a normal game
for three days I've done extremely well
I've had an advantage
the last game didn't go well in Game one
when Wesley so ran over Dominguez and so
let's just calm down and that's exactly
what he's doing now there's a few
variations you can use in the Kali
system one and the most common would be
pawn to c3 but we're seeing more and
more players when they adopt this to
play pawn b3 Bishop here to b2 and why
it's really looking to attack the King
side of the board black many times
depending on how the pawn structure and
the center opens up he'll a lot of times
be looking to attack on the Queen side
of the board Wesley so continues castle
on the King side Bishop b2 think a doe
on the Queen side pawns c5 started to
attack on the Queen side looking to blow
up the the middle of the board pawn
takes Bishop recaptures I almost think
this is good for both sides of the board
Black has both of his bishops lying down
on the King side and white same thing
has both of his bishops sign down on the
Kings side this is opening up the door
for black to have a little bit of
control in the center of the board white
no longer has a pawn or Appice past the
third-ranked so y can stay back a little
bit or you can decide to push a little
bit forward first decides to go ahead
and continue his development after Queen
e2 he asked completed the development
Knight to d7 just getting that last
piece involved and then pawn up here to
c4 looking to blow up the center of the
board Queen d7 finishes development from
black pawn to a3 with the Queen on the
same diagonal as the bishop once one
make sure that doesn't have to worry
about Bishop coming down here to B form
also just solidifies and controls this B
4 square pawn to e5 says yeah I want to
attack the center of the board anytime
your opponent plays a piece anywhere you
always want to look at what was left
behind in this square here on f5 which
he was controlling was left behind and
so Amelia we see the bishop come here to
f5 attacking this night on d7 Wesley
says I'm not too worried about that I'm
gonna continue to push pawn here to e4
and then I had over here to a d4 in the
center of the board Knight to e5 not
looking to give up that night going to
try to control the center with Knight to
e5 and then Bishop back here to h3 and
then pawn g6 pawn before forcing the
bishop to come back Bishop to d6 Knight
to b6 attacking the bishop so both sides
you know kind of going back and forth
Black has done a good job of attacking
the center of the board he does have a
backward pawn here on d5 black has
forced the bishop over here to h3 so no
longer threatening the King side of the
board kind of been no-man's land right
now and then we see Dominguez starting
to push a little bit himself with pawn
to c4 and then getting his knight
involved forcing these bishops to come
back from his opponent vision comes back
here to b8 not really doing as much as
it was before and then pawn recaptures
here on d5 now after the pawn takes on
d5 will see Lanier Dominguez be looking
at bringing his rook over here to c1 as
soon as files open up whether it's a
fully open file like this or send me
open file where maybe the white pawn is
gone but the black pawn is still there
you don't want to swing your rooks over
there to control that file make sure
that no piece gets there that you can't
take advantage of bishop takes on d5 and
then Bishop up here to d4 and this is an
interesting move because a lot can go
wrong in this type of position the
bishops comes down it looks like it's
just taking back that material you
exchange pawns okay Bishop takes yeah
you could have taken with his knight he
decides to take it with his bishop
doesn't seem too crazy many players
would play rook to c1 but this is
actually a pretty big mistake here from
here you would see Knight to d3
attacking both the
okay in the bishop well you're not gonna
be losing your rook here that would be a
mistake so if you play rook to be won
Knight takes rook recaptures but then
Queen to e5 is the deadly move this
threatens mate here on h2 and you're
going to end up losing this rook here on
b2 now it's subtle because Bishop to d4
makes a lot of sense but many people
would just look at this and say yeah the
C file is open I'm gonna go and play
rook over here to c1 and in a blitz game
it's very tough to see you just don't
have a lot of time to think so props to
Dominguez for making sure that he didn't
play the more obvious move and that's
rook here to c1 he first decided to get
his Bishop out of harm's way and plays
Bishop to d4 first Knight comes back to
c6 attacking the bishop rook here to c1
now it doesn't matter any more than I
can't come to d3 and that threat is no
longer there we do see an exchange on
board Knight recaptures on d4 and then
Bishop down e5 so all no Wesley so has
done pretty good here he controls the
center of the board he has a bishop pair
and when you look at pieces you always
want to see you know how much they're
giving to the game if you have a rook
here on a a it's not really controlling
the game too much this rook on c1 is
doing much more controlling this F file
bishop same thing they want to be in an
open game where there's not a lot of
pawns blocking their movement they also
want to be in the center of the board
where they can control most of the board
these two bishops in the center really
giving Wesley so a huge huge attack
anywhere he wants to he can get his
rooks involved going to have a strong
attack from here from White's
perspective Dominguez needs to get his
light square Bishop really involved and
then start to take advantage of these
two knights wall Knights tend to do
better on one side of the board there's
not much going on the Queen side so if
he can really get both of his knights
and start attacked King side he could
have something very very beneficial
start to happen for wife he decides to
go ahead and attack the center of the
board Knight to c4 and black has kind of
a cup
options he could hold on to his Bishop
pair but he's gonna have to concede the
center of the board
or he could decide to give up the bishop
pair and exchange for still holding down
the center he decides to hold down the
center pawn recaptures here on a d4 and
immediately the route comes over here to
d8 so there's an isolated pawn here on a
d4 Wesley sale has a better pawn
structure getting into the endgame and
says hey this was a great exchange I'll
give up my bishop hair so that I can
start to attack this pawn on d4
Dominguez continues with Knight to e5
Bishop back to b7 Queen III Knight d5
attacking the Queen Queen g3 Queen d6
fuze film Frisky maybe pawn to f6
forcing the knight to move and then
continue but decides not gonna worry
about that too much Queen d6 Queen h4
pawn f6 now forcing the Knights and move
Knight c4 Queen down here says all
exchange if you want to usually not
gonna see the Queen take Knight
recaptures just puts a lot of pressure
on his opponent with the knight
attacking the bishop right here then you
can always play Knight down here to e2
check forking the rook on a c1 white
just doesn't have to want to have to
worry about that and then as soon as the
bishop moves the pawn right here is
gonna fall on d4 so that's not gonna be
the exchange that he wants so we don't
see that instead Bishop to e6 King to a
g7 since it is Czech Queen h3 supporting
this bishop here on e6 and then Knight
to e7 not really sure that he had to
play Knight to e7 seems somewhat passive
for me could have had the knight state
in this urn the board play rook F to e 8
this looks fine to me keeps the center
of the board but he decided it was safer
you don't have a lot of time to think so
Knight to e7 what this does do is it
opens up the door for a discovered
attack rook to d4 in wall if they're
playing a longer game a few hours on
board I don't even know that he would
play something like Knight to e7 but
you could look at this and make an
argument that even though technically
this is not as strong a move it just
adds more pressure on his opponent to
make sure that he's seeing all these
discovered attacks and these critical
lines if he doesn't yeah it ends up
being a much better move and that's what
happens the night comes back here to to
e3 and night to e3 is not the best move
he needs to be protecting this pawn on
d4 after the discovered attack he could
do it a few ways he could play Queen to
e3 holding down the fort he could play
pawn to g3 forcing the Queen to come
back
Queen b8 after this and then rook f1
said d1 protecting the pawn both of
those are fine what's not fine in my
perspective is Knight to e3 yeah because
then just rook to d4 and you get a free
pond and you now control the center of
the board Bishop to a2 from here from
dominguez Bishop to c8 just attacking
the Queen Bishop comes back to e6 this
should be 7 never wants to draw here and
have repeating moves rook to e1 so says
okay let's go ahead and get my other
rook involved into the game hasn't been
doing too much at all so good to see him
finally get that involved rook f8 to d8
double-barreling these rooks here on at
the D file and then rook to f1 super
super weak sauce move in my opinion so
bring your rook over here to e1 and then
bring it back to f1 when so much is
going on the center of the board black
continues to add pressure on his
opponent and you're just gonna waste a
couple moves to bring a rook back here
to f1 this to me says white is just
hunkering down trying to find a good
move here doesn't have a lot of time on
the clock and thinks that his pieces
aren't really coordinated and what
doesn't want to make a big mistake so
he's gonna try to hold on see if his
opponent can make a big mistake here
pawn to h5 Wesley so he he feels it he
thinks there's some weakness going on so
he wants to push as much as possible
pawn to g3 Queen back to e5 once makes
sure that he holds on to his material
bishop a2
ship c8 Queen down here to G to Bishop
g4 wants to get it all on the kingside
the board as much as possible Knight
takes and the pottery captures and this
opens up a lot of things the rook can
come over here to h8 also if you look at
the minor pieces bishops do really well
when there's to pawn structures and
things are happening on the on both
sides of the board and if the the
Queen's and the rooks were not on the
board I would say this light square
bishop is probably the better minor
piece because he can control both but
right now because there's so much major
material with the rooks in the Queen's
all the actions gonna be on one side of
the board on one side only that's the
King side Knights tend to do very well
on one side the board so Wesley so
although he has a pawn advantage I think
he also has the minor piece as well as
just the active pieces as well so has a
huge advantage in my perspective looking
at the board state now Dominguez is in a
tough spot this Queen is blocked off
he's not going to be doing anything this
bishop over here on a Tuesday much of
the board these rooks on the first rank
are really not connected except
controlling the first rank here so a
rook here II won sure not doing too much
it does open up the door for the Queen
to come to f1 but Wesley so is going to
continue and get all of his pieces
attacking on at the King side so Knight
to f5 Bishop here b1 has to get over to
the King side rook e8 just loading up on
the square here on e4 rook to c2 is very
odd yes you want to double barrel with
your rook here on e too but it is
blocking just don't really feel like
it's the best option in this position
may be Queen to f1 and just not worry
about getting your rook there bow
bearing here but decides rook here - C -
Queen - a d6 and then rook to e2 and
it's almost like he knew that his
opponent wanted to play rook T - why
else would he block his own bishop and
so he played the perfect move that says
hey if you want to do that I'm gonna
play the defense to that and that is
Queen up here to d6 rooked
to d1 Dominguez didn't have a lot of
time to even think about okay what is he
doing in in contrast to what I'm doing
rook down to d1 we see the bishop take
the pawn on e4 and then Knight to d4
attacking the rook and after rook to e3
we have in my opinion the favorite move
of the tournament and that is Knight to
f3 great great decoy and this is this is
high-level chest that you don't see all
that often many times players will
they'll resign way before this point but
in a blitz anything can happen and so
you see some crazy moves but but to come
to this point is always nice the bishop
takes and then rook to e1 capture in
this particular spots we did see a
resignation if you're curious how it may
continue if you were to take with this
rook then rook down here you've won
Queen comes down here rook recaptures
and then pawn takes the bishop you can
see how this is going to be an easy game
if for some reason the Queen came down
here to f1 to stop that the rook can
take that we can come down take the rook
right here if you want to take the pawn
or if the palm wanted to take the rook
it could do that either way it's going
to end up extremely poorly for whites
has the Queen involved can start
gobbling out material push the pawns on
the Queen side of the board there's just
not much that's dominguez can do in this
position so Wesley so takes the first
two games on day number 4 just to give
you a recap of the six competitors
through day four so you know who one of
the prizes for those Wesley so dominated
in day four against Dominguez so coming
in Dominguez had an edge and had done
extremely well for three days but the
the blitz portion with five-minute time
control was too much Wesley so could not
be stopped and he ended up with a small
victory so congratulations to Wesley so
Nakamura playing to bluff Nakamura
destroyed for four straight days to pull
off and so he wins that one and then we
have
Alexander Ganesha can Fabiana Caruana
and Caruana ended up winning in Caruana
similar to wesley so he was losing
coming into day number four he even lost
all three days not doing too well at all
the following are Caruana one of the
best blitz players in in the world just
dominated this shook on day four and so
heats he walks away with $60,000 so
those are the six competitors that are
done for the next two days we have
Magnus Carlsen ending Liam we will be
covering some of their highlights over
the next two days but hopefully you guys
are enjoying the champions showdown some
different variations of chess that we
just haven't seen too often so it's
always fun to cover that but thanks for
watching I will see you guys in the next
video with Magnus Carlsen